I was fourteen years of age when I
discovered the phone that my sister had
been reading it as she left him to the
table I picked it up I read and within
two sentences
I felt hypnotized that I have no other
way to explain them I had the sense of
an instantaneous deep I'll even say
spiritual connection with the author of
this book a few years ago decided to
take a walk through town and they had a
bookstore there so like all authors were
curious to know you know as ideally
about any of my books out there I went
there I don't no longer remember whether
they had any my book or not because I
was so stunned when I saw they had a
stack of but a yard long if not longer a
vine ram books and fiction and
nonfiction and I the manager came over
and she's you could see now something I
had some interest in this and I said hi
let me ask you a question is this normal
to have this I see you really carry a
lot of rands here that's I'm having a
great admirer myself but does this have
any particular significance and she said
yes a whole new generation that's just
discovered iron ran and every few years
there's a new wave 9 gave a sense of
human possibility that was exactly what
they were not getting at home or in
their culture young people that is to
say she gave people the sense they could
be effective than if they would
persevere stick by your standards work
hard you can achieve something that you
will be proud of find that power than
you find she would say the heroine your
own soul and work toward that
Oh a is a is of course
Aristotle's law of non-contradiction
it's a way of saying you know identity
existences identity quoting Iran that
which is is quoting Iran and a few other
people so it's a way of asserting simply
that a fact is a fact objectivism is the
philosophy defined by iron Rand which
holds reason as the sole source of
reliable human knowledge that insists
that a rational code of ethics is
possible is achievable by human beings
but the emphasis in that statement is
rational what is rational
probably philosophers would have
different opinions about that I would
understand that to simply mean that an
almost common sense basis but you mean
supported by available information facts
and the respect for information that
it's as they report respect for facts as
they are made manifest to us so it's not
the rationalism as the term is used in
philosophy where a person can divine all
the secrets of the universe from reason
false reason is a process of achieving
knowledge it is not itself the knowledge
[Music]
the idea that a highly rational person
is not at the same time a passionately
emotional one is completely false in
fact almost the opposite is true in my
work as a psychotherapist I tell clients
feel deeply to think clearly it is
through emotions that we are able to
experience the significance of various
facts or events or perceptions as they
pertain to our well-being or the lack
thereof so emotions our means of
experiencing the joy of life and the
pain of life
the pleasure of love and the pain of
love when it is the loss and so on my
point being that when we give up our
defenses and our pretenses are not
worried about how people will perceive
us or interpret into what we've just
said if we are willing just to be simple
and uncomplicated or put it out when
it's relevant to express one's thoughts
or feelings then you have a mind you can
talk to then you can understand the
other person better and vice versa ran
like paradox she enjoyed saying things
that she saw who she thought would shock
or surprise a little but she certainly
she thought it was funny to call this
group of alleged individualist the
collective she thought was funny because
was a paradox at a party in my and
members of my home we have a small
dinner party among the guests with Mike
Wallace I am at a certain point in the
evening was trying to explain to the
people there why she did not regard the
Soviet Union as a serious military
throughout the United States and they
were kind of surprised to that and she
said look it's almost impossible for an
American to understand the level of
incompetence which is the norm in the
song as in a communist Society end of
story
[Music]
with regard to drugs in general bran
would have been opposed to the kind of
the recreational use of drugs she would
also be opposed to the government
arrogating to itself the right to make
it illegal she would argue that people
certainly ever write about what they put
into their own bodies so we may say well
we think a rational person wouldn't do
this but that led me to show her an
article which I've been reading which
which was suggesting that marijuana
could confer some very interesting
mental results that are worth
experiencing and he smoked it we're
going to take it in a biscuit and I
showed her the article or I summarized
and I forgot wish and I don't know what
mood she was in that night but she says
let's get someone try it I almost passed
out I mean I thought this this is this
is - by tomorrow she won't remember this
it would let it be right now because
this is but I can't believe nobody will
believe me
I was bothered there was no way to name
Who am I
we didn't have objectivism yet you know
and then somewhere how I'm not I have no
idea how I came across the word
libertarian and I gathered that that
meant like a minimalist view of the
proper functions of state of the
government and I said - I am I think
that could be a very good name for our
political philosophy because it's not a
word in general use now and we like to
have something to for us to call
ourselves so I instead were advocates of
lazy fair capitalism I said I am that
doesn't do it because - unto grounds
number one it puts the emphasis on
business as though those important thing
about libertarianism is business on the
freedom of the marketplace but we need
something more broad something like what
it basically is philosophically globally
not word stands politically but she was
still using conventional language like a
Republican a conservative not and I
would say to her why do you commonly
tell people you're a conservative you're
no more conservative than than that my
pussycat you know I said unanimous our
we're not Republicans and we're not
conservative why do you use that
language I can't understand that and she
thought she's well you're absolutely
right what we really are is something
like radicals for capital D
if you are going to offer a new and
global code of ethics as ran saw herself
doing every code of ethics has to
include something about redemption has
to include something about people making
bad choices even immoral choices but
pulling their life together correcting
whatever they did wrong as best they can
and getting on with their life there is
no treatment of regeneration of your
life there is no treatment of the motion
from failure to success in the moral
sphere in errors of knowledge we would
say well of course we can always correct
errors of knowledge but errors of
morality for example somebody would say
Rand doesn't have any kind of truck for
people to make mistakes and they had
another person there says well that's
not true yesterday look at Hank Rearden
that Outlets drug he made mistakes I
said yeah but they were not moral errors
there were errors of knowledge and he
was willing to pay the full price for
those errors but we're not talking about
areas of knowledge we're talking with
arrows of morality
that would have been such a great thing
to put into that novel if you had a bad
guy who was almost as bad in some ways
as the good guys and then you show
Redemption now you're talking about
something because everybody in this
planet has done things they wish they
had done differently and those things
may be a little bit ashamed of it now or
embarrassed by now so what welcome to
the human race the real thing should the
separates in my books the good guys are
the not so hot guys is what do you want
to do about it now
[Music]